Harry Styles is becoming such an icon
first of all look at those nails I mean
that is a guy who can walk around and do
anything with such confidence he has
tons of rings I mean I couldn't guess
how many rings he has in this wardrobe
and he's got his initials on he's got a
signet ring on here he has a motif ring
going around with the floral motif we
know there's been a ton of thought put
behind it and they really pick each
piece carefully to to work with what
they're trying to say I'm David Allen
25-year master jeweler and diamond tier
making custom jewelry here in New York
City today we're going to be talking
about men's rings and the trends you're
seeing lately
[Music]
the chain link itself in particular the
Cuban link or the Miami Cuban was
popularized in the 80s by likes of LL
Cool J and Run DMC T this became
something of a status symbol also the
more chain you had the heavier you chain
the longer your chain chain is something
in history that was used for protection
to keep themselves safe really a symbol
but now we're moving them to our hands
also to see them set with diamonds to
see them plain to see this link showing
up in subtly different shapes you have a
a sharp flat straight Cuban link you had
this very soft fuller looking Miami
Cuban link you see Jaden wearing a few
of them and they're slightly different
shape and a different width and a
different half you've got one in white
metal you've got one in yellow metal you
can mix these wear them Wilkin Becker's
wearing another very cool chain link
this is an amazing link it is designed
around the horse bits that's a really
common theme through the AMAs design it
has some diamonds on it the metal of it
is really bold looking as well this is
another very particular style of chain
ring that speaks a whole other land it's
very cool very classy I love that
I love what Snoop Dogg is doing he wears
this chain-link ring a lot I see him
wearing it sometimes on its own
sometimes with one pave then sometimes
too I really like what he's doing here
with this whole set where he's got one
pave band in white metal one pave band
yellow gold both of white diamonds and
then the mix of yellow gold and the
white diamond on his bigger ring creates
this amazing palette it just blends
together beautifully
Billy Porter is wearing is another trend
is this black stone with white and
yellow metal so I think these rings are
probably silver and gold mixed together
which is the common thing they're super
bold this black is the first thing you
see and that embellishment on the ring
the detailing the old school setting
work on that one big oval ring he's
wearing has 20 or some odd prongs going
around and holding that stone in on the
other two rings the stones are set in a
bezel which is the metal pushed around
the edge of the stone to hold them in
those two the bezel setting are what
could be an actual signet ring for use
so how a signet ring will sometimes
start is just with the blank stolen and
then that stone is then carved with
whatever you're using as that emblem
he's chosen to just leave them blank
here and really Stark and it creates a
great look oftentimes people will refer
to white metal is silver it's the color
that you're referring to fine jewelry
especially is most often not made and
silver silvers not terribly durable
really soft material gets worn and
damaged very easily with regular wear so
most of the white metal that you're
seeing is going to be platinum palladium
is a hot thing to see today palladium is
a precious metal that was discovered as
a byproduct of mining platinum so
they're chemically not very different
from one another though palladium weighs
47 percent of platinum so it's super
light but also very durable finishes and
wears beautifully like platinum does
Jay Z he's bringing 80s in such a major
way right now from his hair to his
jewelry it's amazing that that silver
and onyx is vintage at this point really
and he wears this great big ring that's
a power ring I mean that's that's the
finger or the ring finger on the right
hand is where Pope's royalty would wear
their big Signet rings Jay Z's doing the
same thing right here lil nas X you see
this stark black and white again but in
a totally different way these are black
diamonds set into either silver or white
gold or platinum Superbowl ball so this
ring isn't just bold because it's big
with a lot of diamonds set on it but
it's this super contrast of these black
diamonds and the white metal it looks
great so turquoise was discovered some
6,000 years ago
the name turquoise comes from the French
word for Turkish so this is where the
material actually came from and it was
brought to Egypt and sold there and used
in mass in Egyptian jewelry turquoise is
mined all over the world though you have
mines in Asia
you have mines on Europe you have mines
in the southwestern US and Mexico most
of us recognize turquoise in native
Indian jewelry super brother this was a
very meaningful stone it has a lot of
energy to it and it represents in it's
different colors different things
turquoise it's not terribly expensive
material I mean there's some very very
fine turquoise that can cost quite a bit
more money but most of the turquoise
that we see especially silver jewelry is
not expensive material so it's something
you haven't seen on red carpet let's say
until very recently I think people are
getting back to in addition to fine
jewelry and lots of diamonds and lots of
polish is taking something that's super
rustic either juxtaposing it with a
super fine tailored style like you see
on Shia LaBeouf he wears this turquoise
ring with the super tailored suit and
got him with his craggy beard and his
way about him and this super fine suit
and the turquoise creates this amazing
juxtaposition in his look and then
you've got someone like Jason Momoa this
is just modern-day warrior this guy he's
wearing this looks to me like Navajo
jewelry it's a very typical of Navajo
design it fits his personality perfectly
and he could rock this on the red carpet
anything so Diplo knows how to put
things together from his clothes to his
jewelry to his accessories you'll see he
wearing black and white and he has his
turquoise on in silver or white gold or
platinum it has a totally different look
then when he's wearing something Brown
or with love color you see him wearing
his turquoise and yellow gold so he's
really careful about things not being
too stark and not being the only thing
you noticed this outfit he's wearing
from his glasses with a little bit of
color they go with the blue and the
turquoise you've got the gold that
matches with the decal on his hat and
his whole outfit and it all blends
together really beautifully so you know
one might call pink feminine I don't see
it as feminine at all it's it's a
beautiful color guys dress head to toe
and painted in and look amazing you see
pink jewelry all over the place up guys
so lil Uzi vert is wearing what looks
like a spectacular pink diamond that I
thought seven or eight carats that stone
it's an oval it's a really rich color it
might not be straight pink meaning
diamonds can have color modifiers in
them that's pretty well a pink diamond
but it has a little bit of brown to it
and I mean look I was wearing it on his
pinky it's me he wouldn't dare wear
anything else on his hand that ring I
think I don't know if I'm speaking out
of turn but that could be a half a
million dollar ring that could be a
multi-million dollar pink diamonds can
be extraordinarily expensive so pink
diamonds they only come from a couple of
places in the world the biggest of which
are the Argyle mines
they've become rarer and rarer though
because the mine is becoming tapped
they're just not any more of them left
so they have officially announced the
closing of the Argyle mines the price of
fine pink diamonds is going to skyrocket
next get your hands up young thug is
wearing beautiful pink sapphire ring
that's big that's probably a 10 or 15
carat stone looks like a platinum
mounting to me it's a big bold ring
really architectural looks like an
asscher-cut stone so that's a square
modified emerald cut you don't see that
often on a sapphire this large so it's a
really rare uncommon cut so the light
play on that it's really super clean
goes beautifully with the clean
architectural lines of this ring so what
most people think of when they think of
sapphire is that really rich deep blue
but you have blue sapphires that are
super pale you have green sapphires
which are not the same green as an
emerald pink sapphires are really
they're super rich in chromium which is
what makes this pink come to the game
and they can be very pale pink to a very
deep pink the way the light plays in the
diamond is a completely different matter
than the way the light plays in the
Sapphire or any other stone for that
matter you can have a pink diamond and a
pink sapphire with the same intensity of
color
the light coming out of them is
completely different let's take for
instance a pink diamond this intensity
and a pink sapphire of this intensity
your pink diamond is going to be 5 X 10
X more expensive than the sapphire
doesn't mean the sapphires are
inexpensive it just means that the
diamonds are a whole other animal
they're so rare that the pink doesn't
show up very often
Anderson Pak is wearing here a big lion
ray nuts it's a lion king the jungle I
mean he's making huge statement wearing
this thing very bold very cool right
Jason Momoa the the skulls the lion he's
got it all going on here I mean the lion
was you know is the protector showing
your power
Kings were Lions all the time this skull
historically is something that was worn
to solemnize a loss loved one and two
mortal eyes yourself to recognize that
life is short and we have to be aware of
these things look at Johnny Depp here
he's wearing these bold skull rings one
of them nodding to the pirate motif
again he's wearing it on the red carpet
and it looks great it's this rough kind
of dark look with a really tailored chic
wardrobe and it works off said he has so
much cool jewelry this dollar sign ring
he's wearing is amazing those are pretty
big diamonds for pave you dollar symbol
each curve is one roll of diamonds real
statement stars are magical right young
thug is a star I mean he's presenting
himself on his hand right there this big
star you know you saw Elton John do
stars back in the day right he's been
wearing them for years but this has
become something that we see on a lot of
different people so on a little baby you
see this amazing star ring with pave
diamonds everywhere you have this Super
Bowl or champion ship shaped ring on his
ring finger that's a massive ring this
diamonds everywhere on these things
these are not inexpensive rings and it's
not 15 carats worth of diamonds in that
it's an incredible piece of jewelry I
[Music]
love what way of always wearing here
his nickname honcho is just all over him
to count how many diamonds are in this
piece of jewelry this is ludicrous he's
got a lot going on on his head but just
work seamlessly on him it becomes a
piece it's not individual rings here
this is really a full wardrobe he's
wearing on his head a Rick Ross seeing
letters and words in diamonds on rings
is something that's becoming more and
more of a trend we already have seen a
trend of words and writing on our
jewelry but the seed in diamonds on
someone's hand it just takes it to the
next level people wear their initials
their names of their kids or their loved
ones their nicknames is no way to do it
wrong jewelry is all about personality
it depends on how you carry it it
doesn't matter what you're wearing as
long as you're wearing it with
personality you can you can take a very
simple piece and wear it in a certain
way and it can scream or you can take a
really ornate piece and have a subtle
way about it's really all about
self-expression